damman une responsabilité immense de nos
gouvernants et en particulier des
manuels macro et de ses gouvernements
successifs
quand emmanuel macron on cherche à nous
faire croire que au fond les coupures
d'électricité qui peut être se dessine
pour cet hiver l'explosion des factures
d'énergie en particulier pour les
entreprises aujourd'hui qui ne sont pas
protégés par le bouclier tarifaire quant
à emmanuel macron cherche à nous faire
croire que c'est le le prix de nos
valeurs et que c'est à cause de la
guerre et bien c'est évidemment un
gigantesque mensonge la vérité oui c'est
un n'est pas du n'est pas lié à la
guerre en ukraine je peux vous en donner
une preuve très simple c'est qu'il ya
deux ans au parlement européen j'étais
intervenu mais je n'étais pas le seul je
veux pas m'en donner le mérite mais
j'étais intervenu pour dire que nous
allions connaître sur le sol européen et
en france en particulier des coupures
d'électricité et que nous allions
connaître des pénuries elles sont
arrivées plus vite que prévu pas à cause
de la guerre en ukraine à cause de
l'état très dégradé de notre parc
nucléaire aujourd'hui à cause de la
fermeture de la centrale de fessenheim
et moi je pense en particulier à tous
les atouts les ouvriers à tous les
techniciens aux ingénieurs de fessenheim
qui sont des gens qui travaillent avec
un souci incroyable d'exigence et
d'intégrité et qui doivent être écoeurée
aujourd'hui alors que la france va
rentrer dans une période de grande
tension sur le plan de son alimentation
électrique qui doivent être écoeurée
d'entendre le président de la république
qui se défausse de sa responsabilité
c'est lui c'est à dire françois lamy
qu'en ce moment quand on nous quand il
est dit que tout cela est dû à la guerre
en irak que c'est le prix finalement que
nous devons payer pour la démocratie
pour nos valeurs vous vous dites c'est
un mensonge c'est le mot que vous avez
utilisé oui c'est un mensonge bien sûr
évidemment la guerre crée une tension
sur l'approvisionnement énergétique de
l'union européenne c'est une certitude
c'est un fait mais d'abord cette guerre
elle devait être anticipée comme faisant
partie des événements qu'il faut
toujours avoir en tête quand la france a
construit depuis maintenant plus de dix
ans sa stratégie énergétique en ne
donnant aucune marge à son système
énergétique s'il ya au fond notre
système il fonctionne sans avoir aucune
marge de sécurité
et bien c'est et irresponsable de se
projeter dans un monde où on jamais à
faire face à des événements de cette
nature